bonjour alors vous plaire merci de
répondre à la question directe ur sur rt
france rétropédalage du land c'est donc
le 26 mai dernier vous étiez sur notre
antenne vous alerte y ait sur des
conflits d'intérêts présumés des auteurs
de cette étude qui semble donc décrié
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous maintenez
vos propos suite à cette volte-face de
la revue britannique puis l'étude a été
publiée le 22 mai et le 28 mai déçu
beaucoup de scientifiques se sont réunis
pour contester cette étude cette étude
des pros out et des antilles raout donc
une pluralité de deux scientifiques
le problème de le problème de cette
étude de l'enset c'est une revue d'une
grande réputation qui se font sur un
historique considérable et de les
personnes dont je parlais les
scientifiques ces lois pertinentes ont
pointé du doigt des carences
méthodologique majeur et on assiste un
détournement du savoir scientifique ce
qui est grave parce que ça te casse la
confiance entre les chercheurs et les
patients j'ai participé à de nombreux
colloques de la société française de
d'éthique médicale présidée par le
professeur christian hervé de
l'université paris descartes et depuis
trois ans cette société pointe du doigt
cette déviance
donc il va falloir travailler parce
qu'il ya des scientifiques sur
lesquelles on peut compter et l'europe
va s'engager en 2021 sur ce qu'on
appelle un plan s pour favoriser l'open
access c'est à dire en disponible
gratuitement à l'ensemble axe communauté
scientifique
toutes les données brutes et c'est en
analysant ces données brutes qu'on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait des données
douteuses voire inventé par exemple il y
avait des données de machines de
réanimation dans des pays en afrique qui
n'en dispose pas et 96 mille patients 96
dossiers et les en deux mois chapeau
l'om est suspendu
des essais cliniques en pleine pandémie
suite à cet article la france de son
côté a suspendu le traitement de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine dans les
hôpitaux pour les patients atteints de
vue du courant navires us écoutez à ce
propos la réaction tout à l'heure de la
porte parole du gouvernement
je crois justement que nous avons
collectivement tort d'en faire un objet
politique
il s'agit là d'un objet scientifique
dans l'abyei sanitaire nous ne devons en
aucun cas mettre de la politique là où
ça n'a pas lieu d'être et je crois qu'on
devrait laisser les scientifiques
travailler tranquillement et sereinement
pour avoir une réponse qui soit claire
compte tenu des connaissances
scientifiques qui sont à notre portée la
suspension de la chloroquine n'a donc
pas été un choix politique selon cib et
n'diaye du coup c'est quoi la prudence
nécessaire ou vrai manque de confiance
de la france en ses capacités
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
propos de la page je ne savais pas que
même si bête engadget et médecins mais
tout tout tout médecin qui lie cette
étude c'est parce qu'il ya un problème
je ne comprends pas que l' oms ou le
haut conseil de santé publique où il ya
des scientifiques ne se sait ne se soit
pas aperçu qu'il y avait un problème sur
cette étude
et je ne comprends pas que notre
ministre olivier ferrand qui est médecin
ok neurologue de renom ne se soient pas
aperçus tv des problèmes que veut on
cacher c'était u2 qui a été financé on
parle de de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros
une étude qui a été piloté par une
société qui s'appelle surgissent fer qui
tout à fait aussi douteuse
je l'avais évoqué tous ces conflits
d'intérêts mais il va falloir ces
dérives il va falloir pour quoi bon
qu'est-ce qu'il faut cacher que ce qu'il
faut cacher il faut faire faut-il faire
du raout bashing ou faut-il faire cacher
l'insuffisance de notre pays la france
face à ce qu vite 19 face à tes cette
crise sanitaire et 1
on a un système guerre d'ego c'est pas
une guerre politique comme le disait la
porte parole
une guerre d'égos et si c'est une guerre
d'égos problème c'est qu'il ya presque
trente mille morts regardez des pays
comme le sénégal où la crise a été gérée
par un élève du professeur out
chloroquine neuf morts regardez le japon
peut d'isolement des masques depuis
longtemps très peu de noirs regardez la
grèce 176 morts chloroquine je ne suis
pas pro ni contre mais je suis un
scientifique
je suis un médecin qui a été élevé
lorsqu'on appelle où tout un médecin ça
doit être douter ça doit mettre son
libre arbitre en fonction travailler sur
la verrerie d'art à citer des normes il
va falloir faire un plan universitaire
important pour que actuellement nous
sommes dans un système d'évaluation des
scientifiques ou les scientifiques sont
évalués sur la quantité et publications
pas sur la qualité
ce qu'on appelle le public or perish et
ça crée une inégalité de majeur dans le
monde de la recherche
parce qu'il ya ceux qui sont dans le
monde de l'édition qui peuvent avoir des
conflits d'intérêts et les thésards les
jeunes chercheurs ce qu'était offrons
des anesthésistes réanimateurs qui
veulent publier
il va falloir les aider ces gens là ils
ont souvent une bourse pour survivre il
va falloir faire une véritable loi cadre
pour l'enseignement supérieur rétablir
la confiance entre la recherche la
publications scientifiques et les
patients
didier rahout avait qualifié le site de
foix heureusement la publication de la
revue the land 7 qui discrédite donc ces
travaux il s'est exprimé hier il avait
déclare il a déclaré hier que ce sont
les pieds nickelés qui ont été créés
cette étude
il s'est également jeté des fleurs je
propose à écouter il ya une haine des
des vraies élites peuvent rêver c'est
nous on va vite et donc le genre
d'ailleurs pourquoi les élites vous aime
pas c'est pas les hélices qui est passée
ce qui n'est pas assez vite
moi je suis une star des maladies
infectieuses j'ai tenu j'ai un cursus
qui fait rêver à peu près n'importe qui
aussi bien la fonction officielle
j'étais le plus jeune président
d'université de france après leur
médecin le projet le plus jeune de tous
les mecs de tous les professeurs la
classe exceptionnelle professeur le plus
ancien dans le grade le plus élevé de
tous pays en médecine
j'ai tout mis dans ma vie donc si vous
laissez moi les 10 mai ce pays de temps
en temps à des crises dans ce cas il
veut décapité son élite et par la
révolution a décapité la boisier
l'inserm en 1981 a décapité les cinq
médecins les plus célèbres de france
avec 1 serait trop pédalage de 2,27 est
ce que c'est une victoire symbolique
pour didier raoult talent père je pense
que c'est une victoire de la vérité
contre la manipulation
on a parlé de cette news j'ai été aussi
accusés de de relier des choses
douteuses paix quant au président de la
république dit big man qui a jamais
problème de masque on dit pas que c'est
une chose
et cette certitude c'est une musique
news monumentale et personne ne dit rien
qu'est ce qui fait de la fin du cachet
qu'est-ce-qu'il le professeur un couteau
c'est quelqu'un d'un peu particulier et
d'utiliser ces termes vous avez montré
un jeu en cours passage où on voit son
ego ressortir mais il a droit d'avoir de
lego c'est quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
souvenez vous il ya 25 ans professeur
out séduit call cas résolu le problème
de la scor à l'appel la fièvre q c'était
une fièvre qui sévissait en suisse et
dans les hautes-alpes
celui qui a trouvé le traitement
d'ailleurs il y avait de la plus rock il
est des macrolides c'est c'est un génie
c'est voilà en tant que médecin brel si
j'avais un
un mandarin comme ça j'aurais envie de
lui ressembler conques jeu qu'on je
comprends tous ces élèves qui ont envie
de lui ressembler et parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui détonne c'est quelqu'un
qui pousse les gens à aller plus loin
mais il a ses habitudes à là on perd
pourtant didier rahout est accusé
d'avoir prescrit de l'hydroxyde leur
quine à certains de ses passions sans
consentement selon des révélations du
canard enchaîné l'agencé nationale du
médicament a déposé un signalement
auprès du parquet de marseille
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas mais en tous les cas si la
chloroquine était le traitement adéquat
il va falloir poser les vraies questions
pourquoi on a voulu cacher pourquoi on a
mis au banc ce ce traitement en trois
ans en trois ans il a été vendu 4
millions de boîtes d'hydroxyde
chloroquine il y a eu 3 111 cas de
complications non mortels 311 cas sur
des sur des passants du sur des patients
qui avaient des députés rabatteuse aider
des comorbidités s'éteint c'est un
médicament qui est prescrit depuis très
longtemps
si ça marche et céline est simple c'est
le mandataire merci à vous faire d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes sénateur les républicains de
la côte d'or et médecin radiologue